there's a woman who's gone viral
a pro-abortion activist who's gone viral
uh thanks of course to our friends at
libs of tick tock for
for
defending the use
of aborted babies
to make biofuel
boarded babies being burned and then
used for electricity the real answer to
that question is nobody really cares
actually you could bake them fillet them
frequency them barbecue
roast
you could broil them
pan fry them i do not care and let's be
honest here if we could burn those
suckers for actual like lights and power
i feel like we're on to something
you guys are so anti-solar
here you go
it's a resource we're gonna have no
matter what
but i mean really though
that this this is what you guys are
pushing now they're burning fetuses for
fuel
i mean it's better than going into a
landfill though right
so this demon is making some conflicting
arguments here the first point is she's
doubting the veracity of what that
pro-life activist at the top is saying
namely that abortion activists are
sending
aborted babies to bio-waste facilities
to be turned into biofuels she says you
you're that's your line now you're
saying that's really happening yes that
that is really happening that had i can
at least say that has happened i am
strongly inclined to believe that that
is still happening but at the very least
even liberal media outlets very
established liberal media outlets i've
got the cbc right here have admitted
that it has happened
tissue
fetal tissue
aborted babies have been sent to bio
waste processing facilities
to be turned into energy that has
happened
okay so just on her factual claims yes
that is happening and then she says well
i don't care if it's happening that's
fine by me that's good isn't that better
than going to a landfill
i don't know if it's better or worse
than than sending
aborted babies to a landfill i think
they should be buried and be given
uh they should be given funerals because
they've been killed and they're people
and people deserve funerals and just
like when your grandma or grandpa die
you're not going to leave them in the
streets to be eaten by dogs and you're
not going to send them to some dystopian
facility to power your televisions at
just like you would treat them with
respect because we recognize that there
is something sort of sacred about a
human body
so too we should do the same thing with
aborted babies
innocent little babies who have been
killed and then she says the line to be
provocative she says i don't care what
you do with them i don't care frequency
them
saute them fry them up i don't what do i
care
and she's trying to be provocative sure
but i i suspect she really believes this
because her argument is it rests
entirely on denying that the babies are
babies
they're not really human well of course
they're human what do you think they are
platypuses no well they're not really
individuals of course they're
individuals they have individual dna
they have they have
individual human processes outside of
the mother even when they're connected
by an umbilical cord they have separate
individual human processes well they're
not really alive of course they're alive
that's why you have to kill them in
order to have an abortion
if they're if they're not alive then you
don't worry don't have the abortion and
nothing will happen right then no of
course what will happen is they will
continue to grow and then they will be
born because they're alive
so so her argument rests on denying that
and saying well it's just a clump of
cells i don't care whatever fry them
frequency them
you sometimes hear this argument with
regard to eating dogs
we all know there's something wrong
about eating dogs there's just something
kind of wrong about it i don't even like
dogs i'm a people person but i would not
want to eat a dog
it seems something wrong about eating an
animal that has
grown and been trained to be man's best
friend to trust human beings and then we
turn on them and eat them and kill them
that would be that seems wrong to me
how much more wrong how infinitely more
wrong would it be to do that sort of
thing to human beings but if you have no
respect for
human dignity for
uh the moral order for the the idea that
humans are more than just flesh and and
blood there are more than just big sacks
of chemicals that we actually have souls
and spirits and that there are things in
this world namely everything that really
matters to us our hopes our dreams our
loves or joys that are beyond the
material world
if you if you deny all of that then yeah
i guess her argument makes sense it's
just unfortunately it's just completely
wrong you're seeing this kind of
radicalism from not just kooks on tick
tock but from elected democrats and
democratic candidates
right now go to helix sleep dot com
slash knowles and enter my boudoir and
take a little looksie at my bed
sit down please enter to my bed but
actually not my bed that's kind of the
whole point you shouldn't be sleeping on
a bed that was made for someone else you
are unique you deserve a bed that was
made for you helix can do it helix sleep
has a quiz that takes two minutes to
complete matches your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you
why buy one made for someone else with
helix you know that you're getting a
mattress made for the way that you sleep
whether you prefer a soft mattress a
medium mattress a firm mattress whether
you want to be cooled down a little bit
because you sleep a little bit hot
whether you've got some spinal alignment
issues maybe you want a plus size
mattress for plus size sleepers helix
has it for you they will match you to
the perfect mattress mattress comes
right to your door comes shipped no big
deal if you do not like it they've got a
10 year warranty you can try it out for
a hundred nights you're gonna love it
though so none of that even matters
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders two free pillows for our
listeners at helix sleep dot com slash
knowles that's helix sleep.com
canadawles did you like that clip i'm
glad you did you got to ring the bell
and subscribe that way you'll get
notifications for all the clips and all
the special interviews and all the
special breakouts and all the episodes
and the whole
michael knowles show
universe
you got to subscribe also go to apple
podcast spotify stitcher wherever you
get your audio podcast type in the
michael knowles show if you would be so
kind leave a 5 star review and we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you